do you see this red paste space shuttle
Engineers are using to glue the thermal
protection system to the airframe of the
Orbiter that's this material which you
can buy from any hardware store this is
RTV silicone or room temperature
Vulcanizing silicone vulcanization
basically just means strengthening and
the name comes from the Greek god of
volcanoes because sulfur which was first
used in the process often comes from
volcanoes the process was first
discovered by by Charles goodar in 1830
he discovered that mixing sulfur and
rubber would result in a material that
could stay solid at higher temperatures
but this new version the silicone modern
version uses iron oxide and titanium
dioxide to stabilize it at higher
temperatures too um which allows it to
be used in the spa Orbiter which you can
learn more about by clicking there's a
related shorts link right here which is
I like I have to talk so fast to fit in
the one minute like short it's amazing
cool go do it